okay we need to talk about last night  it was not okay  you heard colt  colt hurt me first  because he lied  i don't think he lied he just didn't  tell you  no he lied  vanessa sent messenger for me i say  do you continue converse coach and  friends because coach say for me you  know friend more  she said yes me and cold talk every day  and what did you say though you call her  a [ __ ] the same as you told me  you cussed at me yeah i said that enough  name but no for you for vanessa  [ __ ] because i really angry  you have male friends and you don't  think about having a sexual relationship  with them or being in love with them  they're just male friends the same  within me i can have a female friend  without thinking anything more of it  i think everyone just misunderstands  each other and assumes it worse because  they don't know each other  and when you come to vegas you can meet  vanessa we can all  have a drink no  [Music]  you